right new trailer for the hobbit the
desolation of smaug and the first thing
it shows of course is Bilbo Baggins
completely [ __ ] his pants full lots
of these short of your enormity
o Smaug the stupendous
I have never invoked that kind of a
response in any human being who's ever
met me in my entire life but you need
the voice of Cumberbatch and a big
dragon dick there you go I'm looking
forward to the desolation of Smaug I
really enjoyed the Hobbit an unexpected
journey and this one looks like it's
like hey here's although really awesome
[ __ ] now we have more conflict more
throwdowns more dwarves and elves hating
each other we have come to reclaim our
homeland I offer you my help let me know
anyone betray us don't you know good old
racist metaphor is it a good time a lot
more Legolas and a lot more chick from
lost in this trailer it looks like they
have this romance going on Legolas is
growing very far
do not give him hope where there is
nothing hey don't be a [ __ ] tease hot
elf chair it's true that's what he meant
and that's a responsible adult thing to
say to her and it's almost like in the
course of the Hobbit movies and all the
trailers and all the excitement you
almost forget about the ring you're like
oh yeah Bilbo found the ring Evil's all
coming back we see more of that and we
see Bilbo's crack addiction I found
something in the club in town
that's what the dwarves are there for
the dwarves and Gandalf are not there
for some sort of quest to take back
Erebor no they're there for Bilbo's
intervention will you do fun good and of
course Thorin Oakenshield is still
awesome because he should he's Thorin
Oakenshield so he's like i don't trust
anyone
I don't trust elves he'll I hugged Bilbo
and accepted him as part of my
Brotherhood in the last movie and now
he's just kind of expendable to me I
will not risk this quest seriously I get
it in the whole course of things I
suppose he's like one life isn't worth
the whole quest and you see that a lot
of things and that is how things like
this are even in real life or it's like
all that guy's gonna die but we have to
let him die because it's not worth
losing the war they just feel like the
way he said that is how he would have
said it in the last movie now I was like
dude it's Bilbo and of course in the end
of this trailer we get Benedict
Cumberbatch as the voice of Smaug so
ladies if you would please take your
sub-woofer put it on the floor turn the
bass up and you go ahead and sit on that
cuz this one's for you
that is certainly one batch of cumber I
think the guy should voice most
everything that's what I think I think
that his voice is made for voice work I
would love to see Cumberbatch be a mall
Santa this year yeah this Christmas mall
Santa Benedict Cumberbatch - so the
hobbit the desolation of Smaug have you
seen the new trailer and what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more